das ist wirklich ein irrer plan ein
chinesisches forschungs ziehen will
einen erdnahen asteroiden einfangen und
ihn sicher zur erde bringen das soll mit
raumschiffen oder einem schwarm von
sonnen gelingen schon im jahr 2034
könnte so ein brocken von 6,4 meter
durchmesser kontrolliert auf unbewohntem
gebiet niedergehen und somit das leben
auf der erde vor schlimmerem bewahrt
werden vor einer befürchteten kollision
nämlich wie die astro jeden fall
technologie konkret aussieht und ob die
pläne tatsächlich realistisch sind das
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
einen möglichen kandidaten für den
krassen plan eines chinesischen
forschungsteams gibt es schon ein
asteroid der sich noch in etwa 100
millionen kilometern entfernung von der
erde befindet sein gewicht mehrere
hundert tonnen bis 2029 will man ein
mögliches van konzept ausgetüftelt haben
und so könnte man den asteroiden schon
2034 sicher zur erde bringen aber von
vorne
auch wenn es nach science fiction klingt
das konzept stammt aus einem
chinesischen ideenwettbewerb in shenzen
hier sollen forschungsteams motiviert
werden außergewöhnliche und
bahnbrechende konzepte zu entwickeln
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
ja es klingt wie science-fiction jedoch
glaube ich dass es umgesetzt werden kann
die idee hat das mit 59 weiteren
konzepten jedenfalls ins finale
geschafft einer chinesischen
nachrichtenagentur zufolge tüfteln
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
des jan 14 laboratories of space
technology schon an der konkreten
technischen umsetzung für den asteroiden
gefahren die entwicklung von schlüssel
konzepten sei hier noch dringend
notwendig sagt das forschungsteam selbst
zudem sei auch die suche nach geeigneten
kandidaten keinesfalls bereits
abgeschlossen
die idee sieht vor raumschiffe oder
sonden in richtung des aktiven zu
schicken
diese könnten eine art über große tasche
im schlepptau haben die den asteroiden
einhüllt und seine geschwindigkeit
drosselt so könnte er dann stück für
stück in richtung erde gezogen werden
dem konzept zufolge würde dann ein
bereits entwickeltes hitzeschild seine
eintrittsgeschwindigkeit weiter
reduzieren so würde er in die
im fall den sturz auf die erde
überstehen und eben nicht verglühen
dafür müsste seine geschwindigkeit nach
angaben der chinesischen
nachrichtenagentur von 1200 kilometern
pro sekunde auf etwa 140 meter die
sekunde gesenkt werden der kontrollierte
absturz sollte zudem natürlich in einem
unbewohnten gebiet passieren dieser
schritt würde wohl mit zu den größten
herausforderungen überhaupt gehören denn
der asteroid dürfte keinesfalls außer
kontrolle geraten sobald er in die
erdatmosphäre gelangt ist das ziel der
mission sei es objekte die der erde
gefährlich werden könnten aus dem
weltall zu beseitigen
man wolle aber die so eingefangene
asteroiden auch genauer erforschen und
so hinweise auf die entstehung unseres
sonnensystems erhalten zudem könnte man
sich auch die ressourcen die er für
ihnen enthalten zunutze machen metalle
und mineralien die auf der erde nur
selten zu finden sind bislang wurden
missionen zu asteroiden als reine
forschungsansätze durchgeführt die nasa
beispielsweise hat raum fahrzeuge auf
einem asteroiden gelandet eine
japanische sonde hat auch partikel mit
zur erde gebracht aktuell ist die
japanische aktuellen mission hayabusa 2
am start die sich derzeit im orbit um
den us open ein 6 2 17.30 uhr befindet
und später dort auch mal länder absetzen
soll doch der plan der chinesen ist
größer dazu liebt im gegensatz zur
mission die proben zurückbringen wollen
wir einen ganzen asteroiden mit mehreren
hundert tonnen gewicht zurückbringen
lassen der eine potenzielle bedrohung
für die erde darstellt und dessen
ressourcen wir dann nutzen könnten die
nasa hatte seit 2014 übrigens an einem
ähnlichen konzept gearbeitet hier wollte
man potenziell gefährliche hast du ihn
jedoch nicht landen sondern in eine
stabile umlaufbahn um den mond bringen
die us-raumfahrtbehörde hatte diesen
plan im letzten jahr dann aber gecancelt
wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollen
auch extra videos und livestreams nicht
dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal
und nimmt auch noch ein paar privilegien
mit außerdem unterstützen wir uns mit
einem kleinen betrag einfach auf
mitglied werden hier unter dem video
klicken und vielen dank an die schon
dabei sind das macht uns etwas
unabhängiger von den schwankenden
werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube wenn ihr
immer garantie
über aktuelle videos informiert werden
wollte dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die etwas unzulässige abo
box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst
kein video mehr
einfach hier draufklicken und am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal tricks um
social and media abonnieren dafür
einfach hier klicken und aber nicht auf
keinen fall nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken gefährlichste hast du
in etwa nasa rammbock gegen ben you bis
dann bleibt dran
fast vergessen